Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters. This is episode three of my personal journey.
And again, I'm sharing this to be an encouragement. Remember, I'm awarding right now everything
I'm going to share today. I'm talking about what I'm currently doing. And this does not mean
this is what you should be doing. So my kids are like the extremely different than you. And even
if we had the exact same cancer, it doesn't mean we would or should be doing the same thing.
I tested myself and had Michelle test me on different supplements and what to be using.
And this is what I'm doing. So this is only a piece of what I'm doing. I guess I want to keep
these short. So let's walk through this. So these are nutrients that I'm currently doing. This
is what I tested out originally over a year ago about what would be the best thing for what I
am going on because I get I have an extra memory. Pages disease that's metastasized to my colorectal
area and my abdominal lymph nodes. That's what I believe what I have going on. And black sand blood
root tends to work good. So it actually fits the pattern. You've heard me. I know I've talked
about black sand blood root and some other videos that tends to work good for for epithelial
cancers. And my type of cancer is an adenocarcinoma with an epithelial origin. And that's what this tends
to work well on. This seems to help with my symptoms. And I do think this is helping with my
with my cancer knocking it down. I take anywhere between two and six to eight of these a day.
I also take mushrooms. But as I mentioned in another video, I don't take these religiously. I don't
take them every day. These didn't test out for me. But I still just have this this
part of my heart that thinks I should be taking them. So I take these once or twice a week with
my drink back. So my drink back. So I didn't put on here. I'll talk about it next time is I use greens.
And I use modified citrus pectin in my drink. And I put in one of those little blender things
and throw some ice cubes. That's because I like it cold. About three scoops of the greens first.
At least three scoops of the greens first. It just seems like what this just one scoop just
doesn't seem enough for me. I don't know why, but I put about three scoops of the greens first.
About a heaping tablespoon of this. And then I usually will throw in some mushroom mix two, three times
a week. And then I'll take my black sands throughout the day two. And then there's multiple other ones
I take also, but I'll be talking about those two. The reason why I take the modified citrus pectin
this this product also has the IP-6 in it. So I do like this product. Not positive that they're
going to continue to keep this product. I'm testing out another product that may replace this. I'll let
everybody know that. That may be a little bit better. Ben with me for like the time I'm constantly
seeking out the best of the most pure products that we could get. And because there's a lot of
kind of not the greatest products on the market. But this product is a key later. So modified citrus
pectin has been known to help keylate circulating tumor cells. And circulating tumor cells are what
cause metastasis. And I already have metastasis. They don't really feel like having any more metastasis
for the fun of it. So I'm using this for the metastasis. But I'm also using this because
what I tested for cause for me it came up mercury toxicity. Which isn't a surprise because
way we were raised I was eight out of nine kids my parents brought us to like the cheapest dentist in
town. And we had our belts filled with mercury. Took me years to get all the mercury out of my teeth.
That's part of why I hasn't have a nasal problem because I have nasal polyps because of a poor
dental procedure where it's filled mercury into my body. And I ended up instantly with nasal
polyps actually to get it to that whole episode. But that was about eight years ago, nine years ago now.
And I was like as close to death as I ever been to take goodness for
what's that nasal spray you can't even it's it's one this you breathe in. Private teeth missed.
It's not even on the market anymore. I think it's you have to get it through a prescription now and
they don't even it's not the brand isn't even exist. But praise God that you could get it over the
counter at that time because literally there was two times that I I think I really do think I would have
died. My my throat was so closed enough. I remember one instance. Oh, this is right after this
dental procedure is about about a half after it was you got sicker sicker sicker sicker sicker took me
three months to figure out it was the mercury and I had to call the dentist and ask the teeth that he
had on record that they were mercury fillings that he didn't take any precautions. But that's a whole
other story. So it doesn't it doesn't surprise me that mercury is the issue because I've had dental
issues for years and years and years. So and mercury has been a big issue for me for for decades and
decades. So that's why I take this. But modified citrus pecan historically for cancer is taken to help
by circulating tumor cells as a key later for circulating tumor cells. There's been numerous
studies that proved that it could be very beneficial for that. This also has IP-6 in it which IP-6 is
a key later as well. But IP-6 is also a cancer killer. So IP-6 kind of does double duty. We're
modified citrus pecan. It's not a cancer killer. It's a binder key later of of minerals. It's a key
later of circulated tumor cells. So that's why you take this now. Obviously mushrooms have polysaccharides
and the polysaccharides in mushrooms are really your immune stimulators. So we're going to talk a lot
more about polysaccharides because of the stube product that we have. And they just started taking two
weeks ago, which I think really helped is helping me a lot. So I'm going to episode four is going to
be totally on that. And this one has been a great product for me for quite some time and really
good products for multiple patients that I have. All right. So thank you very much for episode three
and we'll talk very soon.